et ce matin nous avons le plaisir de
recevoir le professeur de sociologie
Gérald Bronner
en septembre 2021 le professeur Bruder a
été chargé par le Président de la
République de se pencher entouré d'un
collège d'experts sur les répercussions
induites par la numérisation croissante
de la société et plus particulièrement
sur le traitement et la réception de
l'information par nos citoyens et la
diversité des membres de la commission
que vous avez présidé monsieur Brunner
composé d'historiens de politologues de
juristes de journalistes d'enseignants
de sociologue a constitué une vraie
richesse pour aborder les enjeux
multiples des effets du numérique sur la
société
l'ambition fixée à votre commission
était très élevée puisqu'elle devait
établir de manière synthétique l'état
des connaissances sur les désordres
informationnels à l'air numérique et
proposer des recommandations pour y
faire face donc nous souhaiterions donc
pour voir vous entendre présenter à
grand traits les principales conclusions
de vos travaux qui prolonge en partie
l'analyse que vous aviez pu présenter
dans votre livre paru en 2021 apocalypse
cognitive dans cet ouvrage vous
présentiez déjà les risques de position
de plus en plus forte et de plus en plus
précoce au numérique et aux réseaux
sociaux et vous mettiez brillamment en
lumière les biais cognitifs induits et
les dangers qu'ils peuvent entraîner
dans la compréhension de la formation
donc pouvez-vous nous dire de quelle
façon la commission que vous avez
présidé vous a permis de confirmer le
cas échéant et de préciser ses premières
analyses et plus particulièrement sur
les logiques algorithmiques
pourriez-vous nous présenter les billets
qu'elles peuvent susciter les moyens de
contrer ses effets pour garantir plus de
neutralité donc au moment où vont
débuter au sein de notre commission des
affaires culturelles des travaux de la
mission flash sur l'éducation critique
aux médias dont les rapporteurs sont
madame violette speedbou et Monsieur
Philippe Balard il nous est apparu
essentiel de recevoir le présent de la
commission sur les lumières à l'air du
numérique et je suis en effet convaincu
que les analyses du rapport de votre
commission viendront utilement nourrir
le travail de cette mission est plus
largement de notre commission
donc je vais vous donner la parole pour
une quinzaine de minutes avant que
s'engage à la phase de questions et de
réponses avec les députés je voudrais
juste te prévenir mes collègues pour une
raison
familiale monsieur Bronner et contraint
de nous quitter plutôt que prévu puisque
en train doit le ramener en Lorraine non
mais il poussera jusqu'à 11h mais mais
voilà mais je préfère vous le dire
maintenant pour être concis dans les
réponses dans les questions et concis
dans les réponses aussi mais bon ça mais
voilà pour pour vous le dire il y aura
pas de marge on n'arrivera pas à tirer
au-delà puisque la SNCF
mais
voilà on va on va parier sur sur les
trains à l'heure monsieur bronzer c'est
à vous merci
à vous toutes et tous de votre
invitation à venir m'exprimer à propos
du rapport et très au-delà à propos d'un
sujet qui je crois nous concerne tout
pendant une quinzaine de minutes ce
serait évidemment bien trop bref pour
être exhaustif mais je sais que vous
aurez probablement beaucoup de questions
et j'essaierai d'y répondre aussi
clairement que possible dans la mesure
de mes compétences qui sont très
limitées hélas vous vous en apercevrez
une question qui nous importe tous je
crois qu'il y a quelques années il
fallait consacrer un certain temps
d'abord pour établir le fait et pour
convaincre qu'en effet
le monde numérique tel qu'il se
présentait devant nous était de nature à
nous apporter beaucoup de choses très
positives il faudrait revenir aussi mais
nous allons focaliser notre attention
dans le moment de notre échange sur un
certain nombre d'externalités négatives
des processus qui sont impliqués et bien
dans ce que j'ai appelé à plusieurs
reprises la dérégulation du marché de
l'information
qui s'est profondément modifié et à ce
titre il n'y a pas lieu de s'étonner que
ça implique de profonde modifications
sociales évidemment mais aujourd'hui il
y a plus besoin de consacrer beaucoup de
temps à cela puisque les grandes
institutions internationales que ça soit
l'ONU l'OMS évidemment on songe à
l'institution européenne avec les
récentes inventées récentes avancées
pardon du DSA le digital
bien plus besoin de consacrer beaucoup
de temps pour nous convaincre
collectivement qu'il y a là un sujet qui
mérite de s'y intéresser en effet
premièrement d'abord quelques quelques
faits
un fait qu'il est difficile de contester
c'est que aujourd'hui la disponibilité
de l'information et c'est un des aspect
de la dérégulation de ce marché a
atteint des proportions et de très loin
incomparable si on jette un regard
rétrospectif sur l'histoire de
l'humanité en 2005 on avait produit 150
hexapides de données ce qui est tout à
fait considérable et en 2010 on en avait
produit 8 fois plus et pour ne pas vous
faire rouler sous les chiffres disons
que dans les deux dernières années qui
viennent de s'écouler nous avons tout
simplement produit 90% la formation
disponible sur la planète Terre ce qui
est évidemment proprement inimaginable
en d'autres termes notre cerveau qui est
un outil absolument formidable
probablement le plus complexe de
l'univers connu un million de milliards
de connexions dans une petite boîte
crânienne évidemment on l'utilise pas
tous de la même manière ça va être un
des sujets dont on va parler peut-être
mais n'empêche que malgré l'excellence
de cet outil aucun d'entre nous et
capable d'absorber l'intégralité de ces
informations ça veut dire qu'il faut
faire un choix et nous sommes confrontés
à un dédale cognitif et la question
fondamentale c'est de savoir si dans ce
dédale nous avons plus de chances de
rencontrer Minotaure ou le fil d'Ariane
qui va nous orienter vers les lumières
pour reprendre le terme du titre de la
commission que j'ai présidé en effet et
que je n'ai pas choisi mais que je
trouve tout à fait excellent donc je ne
veux pas critiquer ce ce titre les
lumières à l'air numérique c'est
exactement ça pourquoi parce que là
aussi bref incursion dans le passé les
le siècle des Lumières nous avait fait
une promesse un espoir et peut-être un
espoir un peu trop optimiste
puisque un certain nombre de philosophes
de penseurs
misés sur le fait que en ma rendant
l'information disponible et en
permettant à chacun d'entre nous d'avoir
un niveau d'éducation acceptable et nous
avons largement rempli je crois que la
contemporalité a largement rempli cet
objectif et bien nous irions presque
mécaniquement vers des sociétés de la
connaissance pourquoi parce que l'idée
qui a derrière c'est que finalement sur
un marché libre des idées dans le fond à
moyen terme au moins il y a long terme à
coup sûr ce serait l'idée les plus
rationnels qui finiraient par s'imposer
dans cette concurrence seulement cette
conclusion je dirais libérale et un peu
trop optimiste qu'il s'agit peut-être de
discuter ensemble et que nous avons
discuté dans ce rapport nous avons en
effet quelqu'un qui étude qu'en tout cas
à court terme ça ne soit pas le cas il y
a pas besoin d'être sociologue pour
observer la façon dont les choses se
passent et voir que finalement l'empire
des croyances ne disparaît pas
facilement à l'horizon des progrès de la
connaissance c'est que progrès de la
connaissance et empire des croyances
bien entretiennent pas un rapport de
vases communicants en réalité cette
métaphore est trop simple ce que l'un
gagne l'autre ne le perd pas forcément
et peut-être même parfois l'un dans
certaines circonstances peut irriguer
l'autre c'est ça que nous avons un peu
essayé de démêler parce que les enjeux
sont très importants pour nous tous on
envoie d'ailleurs déjà c'est pas dans le
futur là c'est pas de la science-fiction
c'est une situation déjà présente songée
par exemple à ce qui se passe au Brésil
un pays qui est extrêmement clivé mais
sans aller regarder de l'autre côté de
l'Atlantique regardons simplement de
notre pays comment les débats le moindre
débat se polarise aujourd'hui il y a une
indignation collective tous les deux
jours sur Twitter si je vous parle d'un
certain nombre de de ces indignations de
ces objets le temps que je les dise ils
sont ils sont presque déjà défraîchis
puisque
beaucoup d'études montrent que ce qui
caractérise aujourd'hui les échanges
d'idées c'est la polarisation à la fois
affective et politique
une très belle étude de la Stanford
University a montré que parmi les pays
de l'OCDE qui était mesurés les deux
pays qui sont les plus polarisés ça vous
étonnera pas ce sont les États-Unis en
premier lieu et en deuxième lieu la
France il y a donc lieu de affectivement
en tout cas il y a donc lieu de prendre
ce sujet au sérieux car qu'est-ce qui
nous menace dans l'absolu
ce qui nous menace c'est tout simplement
la fracture de ce qu'on appelle le socle
épistémique commun ou en d'autres termes
de notre socle intellectuel comme un de
notre espace de débat la démocratie dans
son coach génétique même c'est un espace
politique où il y a des bas et vous en
êtes les vivants représentations
heureusement que nous ne sommes pas
d'accord tous d'accord sur les mêmes
sujets c'est évidemment le débat le
débat contradictoire qui je crois fait
évoluer les choses mais à condition
évidemment que les arguments qui soient
échangés soit commenturable
c'est à dire qu'un débat est cumulatif
fertile à condition qu'on situe bien
dans un même espace intellectuel or
encore une fois la récente actualité en
particulier pendant la pandémie nous
montre que nous pouvons débattre
l'infini dans des espaces finalement
intellectuels différents et pour le dire
d'une formule ce qui pourrait nous
menacer c'est de vivre dans la même
société mais plus tout à fait dans le
même monde et jetons un regard sur ce
qui se passe aux États-Unis là une autre
étude du MIT a montré par exemple qu'au
sein même des médias conventionnels les
médias par exemple démocrates ne cite
quasiment plus les médias républicains
et réciproquement tout simplement parce
que les uns et les autres sont persuadés
que le camp adverse ment en quelque
sorte et vous le savez une partie non
négligeable c'est le moins qu'on puisse
dire des électeurs républicains par
exemple sont persuadés aujourd'hui que
l'élection a été volée aux États-Unis et
que c'est Donald Trump le président
légitime
donc cela illustre le risque que je
mentionne c'est-à-dire vivre dans la
même société mais plus tout à fait dans
le même monde est-ce qu'on est
exactement dans la même démocratie quand
une partie non négligeable des électeurs
pensent que le président élu c'est a et
quand une autre penses que le président
élu c'est un autre individu B bon ça
nous pose un problème considérable et
quelquefois
on me pose la question on nous a posé la
question nous étions 14 un membre de la
commission il était il était rappelé
finalement qu'est-ce qui a changé parce
que les fausses informations ce qu'on
appelle les infox les théories du
complot etc tout ça a toujours existé je
veux dire même les arguments
anti-vaccins j'ai eu l'occasion de
diriger une thèse sur le sujet et qui
qui soulignait que finalement les
arguments anti-vaccins existaient depuis
l'origine même du vaccin dès que les
vaccins sont apparus il y a des gens qui
étaient contre les vaccins avec des
arguments qui étonnamment sont pas si
dissemblables de ceux qu'on retrouve
encore aujourd'hui alors que je crois en
tout cas c'est la position je défendrai
ici un contestablement le vaccin sous
toutes ses formes a fait la preuve qu'il
est un des grands bienfaits pour la
santé publique du du 20e siècle avec
l'hygiène et quelques autres
dispositions et pourtant on est encore
donc aujourd'hui et face à une pandémie
une partie de la population qui certes
très minoritaire mais ça va être une des
questions justement que je vais que je
vais mettre en avant qu'ici oppose alors
qu'est-ce qui a changé et bien ce qui a
changé pour le dire rapidement
et pour engager peut-être la
conversation avec vous pour ne pas
abuser les 15 minutes qu'on va
généreusement octroyer
je dirais trois éléments et je serai pas
donc exhaustif mais pour qu'on parte sur
des bases un peu claires je dirais qu'il
y a quand même trois choses qui ont
fondamentalement changé oui bien sûr
tout ça existait auparavant mais ce qui
a changé premièrement c'est la façon
dont l'information est éditorialisée
qu'est-ce que c'est que
l'éditorialisation de l'information par
exemple c'est l'ordre dans lequel va
apparaître l'information quand vous
essayez de vous informer et la
récurrence l'obsession pour certaines
informations cela a considérablement
changé
auparavant dans le monde d'avant comme
on disait il y a quelques décennies
l'éditorialisation de l'information se
faisait sur le marché public parce que
la théorie de la communication appelait
les gatequipers c'est-à-dire les
gardiens du seuil si vous voulez qui
était-il vous par exemple
des gens comme moi le professeur d'une
diversité qui faisait de la recherche
des patrons de syndicats des bâtons
d'entreprise et puis bien sûr les
journalistes en premier lieu donc c'est
la profession d'éditorialiser
l'information c'est-à-dire puisque nous
ne pouvons pas parler de l'intégralité
des choses qui agitent le monde il faut
faire des choix qu'est-ce qui est
important etc alors on peut apporter
bien des critiques à l'éditorialisation
qui était faite par les guêpeskeeper et
entre autres qui n'étaient pas très
démocratique puisqu'en effet une portion
très minoritaire des citoyens pouvaient
étaient considérés comme légitime à
prendre la parole dans l'espace public
donc ce qui a apporté de sans doute
positif internet c'est déjà ce premier
élément c'est à dire la démocratisation
de la prise de parole aujourd'hui si
vous avez un compte Facebook ou un
compte Twitter ou même Tik Tok par
exemple vous pouvez donner votre point
de vue par exemple sur le vaccin mais
vous ça veut dire aussi que vous pouvez
contredire un grand professeur de
médecine sur la question et donc il y a
une concurrence généralisée des points
de vue c'est ça qui caractérise
peut-être la société la situation
contemporaine et l'éditorialisation se
fait aujourd'hui en grande partie par
les algorithmes qui préside au réseau
sociaux par exemple certaines
informations vont être mises en avant
alors certes pour que on se trompe pas
de plus en plus de personnes s'informent
aujourd'hui sur les réseaux sociaux et
pour les jeunes c'est tout à fait
considérable et sur des réseaux sociaux
très spécifiques pour les jeunes
notamment tic-tac ou Instagram 40%
n'est-ce pas de ce qu'on appelle la
génération Z si si informe et peut-être
qu'on y reviendra puisque une récente
enquête de newsgard donc postérieur à la
publication du rapport montrer qu'on
avait un taux de fausse information y
compris sur les informations générales
parent sur TikTok qui à vos idées les
20%. ce qui est extrêmement préoccupant
20% de fausses informations c'est
absolument gigantesque en fait parce que
la fausse information heureusement elle
reste très minoritaire serait quoi un
monde où il y aurait 50% de fausses
informations dans toutes les
informations qu'on peut lire ça
deviendrait évidemment invivable
donc cet éditorialisation elle se fait
aussi par une logique algorithmique même
si effectivement nous continuons si nous
informons sur les réseaux sociaux à
aller lire sur les réseaux sociaux des
articles de presse c'est ça le paradoxe
seulement ces articles de presse ne sont
plus dispatcher comme il était dans un
journal certains articles vont être mis
en avant de façon obsessionnelle par qui
par nous c'est-à-dire par l'économie de
l'attention parce qu'il nous intéresse
or une des caractéristiques des grandes
entreprises du net du numérique c'est
que leur business model si je puis
m'exprimer ainsi et fonder sur le fait
de capter notre attention c'est à dire
de nous maintenir captif le plus
longtemps possible sur leur plateforme
pourquoi parce qu'ils vont convertir ce
temps d'attention n'est-ce pas en
capital économique via par exemple les
publicités rappelez-vous vous le savez
sans aucun doute que une partie de la
manne publicitaire très importante a été
captée par ses grandes entreprises elles
étaient captées à qui bah précisément
aux professionnels de l'information et
aux journaux ce qui fait qu'il y a un
appauvrissement aujourd'hui du
journaliste qui a un vrai problème de
survie économique alors que c'est un
enjeu de bien commun évidemment la
qualité de l'information donc les
algorithmes redisent patch selon
d'autres logiques que ceux de l'intérêt
général c'est ce cette redistribution de
l'information via les algorithmes et il
se fait selon donc une logique de
lattention par exemple quand nous avons
interrogé auditionné plutôt prendre sa
sauvegarde et je crois que vous l'avez
fait ici aussi à l'Assemblée nationale
elle nous a rappelé que pour reprendre
un exemple mais je ne voudrais pas
spécialement mettre un projecteur
négatif sur cette entreprise Facebook
mais c'est quand même le plus grand
réseau social à l'heure actuelle sur sur
la terre et bien Facebook qui a pendant
longtemps mis en avant le lesoticônes
colère c'est à dire qu'un message qui
était assorti de l'émoticône colère
avait 5 fois plus de visibilité qu'un
message qui était assorti seulement de
l’émoticone like c'est ça
l'algorithmisation et l'éditorialisation
algorithmique plutôt de l'information
c'est-à-dire qu'on va mettre en avant
des messages qui sont susceptibles de
nous mettre en colère non pas parce
qu'on veut nous mettre en colère enfin
je suis pas dans la tête de des
dirigeants mais je pense que c'est pas
ça si on est une interprétation par
simonieuse c'est tout simplement parce
que la colère et la conflictualité ce
sont des informations qui intéressent
notre cerveau donc c'est une façon d'âme
sonner notre attention et nous maintenir
plus durablement sur les réseaux social
évidemment quelque chose va nous mettre
en colère donc on va on va faire un
commentaire on doit absolument
contredire c'est
chose très importante l'autre sur
Internet sont des batailles qui vont se
livrer et peu à peu évidemment et bien
cette polarisation dont on parle et bien
elle est mise en avant ça c'est là donc
la première chose l'algorithmisation de
l'information le deuxième point
est de rappeler encore une évidence
pardon mais nous sommes nous autres les
êtres les êtres humains des animaux
sociaux profondément sociaux ce qui veut
dire que dans le fond ce que nous savons
véritablement par nous-mêmes ce que nous
connaissons ce que nous serions capables
de démontrer par des arguments tient
pardon je le dis aussi bien pour moi que
pour vous dans le cru d'une main en
réalité la plupart des choses que nous
prétendons de savoir nous le tenons sur
la foi de la confiance que nous mettons
dans certaines communautés expertes par
exemple ou dans autrui tout simplement
et c'est bien c'est un bien parce que ça
permet à l'humanité évidemment de
progresser dans la connaissance grâce à
la division intellectuelle du savoir
donc en fait ça veut dire que la part de
ce que je sais dans une société de la
connaissance par rapport à ce que l'on
sait elle tente à diminuer
proportionnellement donc la confiance
est un élément central dans les
démocraties de la connaissance mais
c'est précisément la confiance qui est
grippée dans notre société là beaucoup
de sondages le montrent
vous en êtes d'ailleurs les objets aussi
nos concitoyens ne font plus confiance
aux politiques ils font de moins en
moins confiance aux médias et même dans
certains domaines ils ne font pas
confiance à l'expertise scientifique
dans certains domaines parce qu'ils font
confiance à la science en général mais
dès qu'on regarde je dirais au
microscope certains thèmes et bien on
voit que il y a des méfiances qui sont
en inadéquation avec l'existence de
consensus scientifique sur certains
sujets
et donc comment s'établit la confiance
et bien c'est ça le problème c'est que
les réseaux sociaux ont organisé en
quelque sorte
[Musique]
un dérèglement de ce qu'on appelle le
calibrage social c'est-à-dire qu'encore
une fois nous avons toujours tenu compte
de la vie des autres pour nous faire
notre propre point de vue mais la
question que nous devons nous poser
c'est aujourd'hui qu'est-ce qui préside
à la visibilité du point de vue des
autres et vous comprenez bien que les
réseaux sociaux ont totalement de ce
point de vue
dénaturer le calibrage social parce que
ce qui est de la visibilité des autres
va venir aussi de la popularité des
contenus donc on revient à la à la à
l'éditorialisation algorithmique plus un
contenu populaire c'est ce qu'on appelle
le biais de popularité plus nous aurons
tendance cet esprits paribus
c'est-à-dire toutes choses égales par
ailleurs évidemment si on a déjà des
convictions sur un sujet ça va moins
nous impacter mais en général la
popularité des contenus a une influence
statistique sur notre point de vue sur
les choses en particulier donc quand
nous n'avons pas de point de vue encore
établi sur un sujet par exemple sur des
sujets extrêmement techniques là
aujourd'hui on parle beaucoup des des
retenues d'eau il y a des controverses
autour de des questions je pense que
dans une semaine on parlera ça sera un
autre sujet mais enfin là les réseaux
sociaux s'enflamment je prends
absolument pas position sur ces
questions parce que d'abord j'y ai pas
mis le nez mais voyons bien qu'il y a
plein d'arguments c'est très technique
qui s'échangent qui croient en fait et
bien vous allez probablement croire sur
un sujet quand vous n'avez pas le temps
de vous y intéresser à la popularité du
point de vue qui va être visible sur
votre réseau social à vous parce que
vous allez voir statistiquement plus
d'arguments et tous les arguments sont
assez convaincants c'est ça le problème
or un des résultats les plus solides des
ce qu'on appelle les sciences sociales
computationnels qui ont vraiment
commencé au niveau mondial sur les
sujets de fake news à partir de 2016
donc c'est assez récent et on commence à
avoir pas mal de données
et un une des données les plus solides
c'est que la dérégulation du marché de
l'information et la profiter beaucoup à
ce qu'on appelle des groupes
minoritaires mais qui sont très très
motivés à faire valoir leur point de vue
qu'on se comprenne bien c'est pas parce
qu'ils sont minoritaires qu'ils ont tort
mais simplement en tant que démocrates
on doit s'interroger sur la visibilité
d'un certain nombre d'arguments qui ne
sont pas représentatifs mais qui vont
être pris pour de la représentativité en
raison du biais de popularité que je
viens d'évoquer C'est ça la vraie
question en réalité c'est ce que nous
avons appelé dans notre rapport la
diversité inauthentique
diversité inauthentique c'est-à-dire
qu'il est très important démocratie de
maintenir des points de vue très
minoritaires éventuellement quel que
soit les sujets sauf qu'en ça on fera la
loi française bien sûr parce que c'est
ça la démocratie simplement est-ce que
on maintient bien ce qu'on protège bien
notre liberté de jugement lorsqu'on est
exposé de façon majoritaire à des points
de vue qui par ailleurs sont
minoritaires et par exemple sur des sur
des plateformes de vidéos YouTube nous
savons parce que les la science nous le
montre que sur certains sujets des
points de vue très minoritaires vont
être mis en avant par les algorithmes
tout simplement parce que sont des
enjeux de conflictualité par exemple on
sait notamment que l'extrême droite
pendant un temps était sur représenté
sur cette plateforme que les
propositions conspirationnistes étaient
sur représentées et que par exemple des
vidéos climato-sceptiques étaient
sur-représentées donc c'est important si
vous rappelez qu'un certain nombre de
catégories de la population particuliers
les jeunes utilisent ce genre d'outils
pour s'informer sur des sujets qui
peuvent être technique encore une fois
donc ce que montre aussi et j'ai
vraiment arrivé à la fin de mon
introduction ce que montre aussi la
science récente et poste post rapport
donc je vous parle de papier qui sont
vraiment très très récent c'est
l'existence donc dessus
qui représentent 1% en réalité de la de
la population des réseaux sociaux et qui
publie 33% des contenus donc vous voyez
c'est asymétrie elle est tout à fait là
et pour finir tout à fait je dirais que
tout de même une bonne nouvelle
c'est que un des résultats que auquel
aboutit notre rapport c'est que parmi
toutes les variables parce qu'on n'est
pas égaux face aux fausses informations
il y a des variables qui prédisent mieux
que d'autres les les l'endossements de
certaines fausses informations par
exemple la variable politique il est
évident que quand on est de droite on va
avoir plus de chances de croire à une
fake news de droite qui condamne la
gauche et quand on est de gauche c'est
pareil
donc il y a des variables politiques qui
permettent de prédire et d'ailleurs
toutes les variables idéologiques ce que
l'on croit préalablement et bien va nous
livrer à ce qu'on appelle le biais de
confirmation c'est à dire aller chercher
des informations qui vont dans le sens
de nos croyances et on est tous pareils
donc là je jette la pierre à personne si
ce n'est je dois le dire aussi parce que
la science aboutit à ce genre de
résultats qu'on a quand même des
courbons J et que il y a une asymétrie
très nette une propension de l'extrême
droite à propager un peu dans tous les
pays d'ailleurs plus de fausses
informations que les autres catégories
politiques et un peu aussi l'extrême
gauche c'est pour ça que on parle de
courbe de courbe en J
un peu l'extrême gauche et plus
l'extrême droite donc c'est une courbe
en J et on retrouve un peu ces résultats
dans tous les pays ça c'est un fait le
réel est un os comme disait Hegel c'est
comme ça et mais entre toutes les
variables je sais pas si j'aurais dû
évoquer les variables politiques hein
mes chers
on va laisser le l'orateur terminé puis
ensuite on pourra prendre les questions
des groupes merci et pour terminer tout
à fait en fait entre toutes les
variables dont j'aurais pas dû évoquer
celle-ci
entre toutes les variables celles qui
prédit le plus la probabilité de chance
de basculer dans la fausse information
c'est pas la variable politique c'est
même pas la variable de niveau d'étude
par exemple qui est assez prédictif
pourtant sur certains sujets comme le
conspirationnisme c'est ce qu'on appelle
lazy thinking c'est à dire la pensée
paresseuse en d'autres termes le fait
que dans certaines circonstances et en
raison aussi de la façon dont le monde
numérique se configure autour de notre
raisonnement dans certaines
circonstances
on peut observer une baisse de notre
vigilance épistémique c'est à dire notre
vigilance intellectuelle et ça c'est
plutôt une bonne nouvelle en d'autres
termes il s'agit d'une des solutions
possibles au problème c'est à dire qu'on
peut on connaît aujourd'hui les moyens
d'activer la pensée analytique ce que
certains aussi appellent la pensée
critique ce que je préfère appeler la
pensée méthodique et c'est pourquoi nous
avons suggéré c'est une de nos
recommandations parmi les 30 de proposer
une véritable révolution pédagogique qui
n'aurait d'ailleurs qui serait pas
forcément très coûteuse et qui je
croiserait assez bien accepté à la fois
par les professeurs c'est tout à fait
essentiel aussi bien par les parents
d'élèves c'est dire proposer à
l'ensemble de nos concitoyens les plus
jeunes évidemment mais pas seulement
des outils
d'affffffffffermissement si je peux dire
de la pensée méthodique parce que ce qui
nous attrape en quelque sorte dans les
fausses informations c'est aussi le fait
que souvent elles vont dans le sens de
nos attentes intuitives
pour n'en prendre vraiment qu'un exemple
est terminé madame la Présidente par
exemple nous avons tendance à confondre
les corrélations et les causalités c'est
une sale dispositif intuitive que qui
est présent en chacun d'entre nous mais
ce dispositif nous pouvons n'est-ce pas
le combat quand j'enseignais les
statistiques à l'université c'est la
première chose que j'enseignais à mes
étudiants il faut pas confondre
corrélation et causalité et à force
d'exercices ils finissait par comprendre
tout simplement et à se méfier de leur
propre intuitions bien je pense qu'il
faut penser
probablement une forme de révolution
pédagogique qui puisse mettre à
disposition donc je faisais des plus
jeunes mais aussi penser pourquoi pas la
formation continue puisque nous avons en
France toutes sortes de dispositifs pour
offrir pour proposer sans l'imposer à
nos concitoyens un certain nombre
d'outils pour nous permettre à tous de
faire notre Déclaration d'Indépendance
mentale et c'est probablement la façon
la moins liberticide de réguler ce
marché de l'information parce que son
zonzi quand on propose de réguler ce
marché on parle d'opinion et il est
toujours très risqué de proposer une
régulation du marché des opinions en
tout cas quand on est un démocrate ce
que nous sommes tous ici merci merci
Monsieur broner pour cette exposé
liminaire
passionnant peut-être un peu long pour
certains mais passionnant en tout cas et
vous avez répondu par avance quand même
un certain nombre de questions mais mes
collègues on a encore plein plein à vous
poser et donc nous allons commencer avec
le groupe Renaissance par Fabienne
Colboc
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Professeur géraldreneur comme vous
l'avez rappelé et présenté dans votre
rapport il y a de forts enjeux autour du
numérique des enjeux qui touchent
directement à la cohésion nationale et à
notre démocratie ce travail s'inscrit
dans la continuité des mesures
législatives de régulation des grandes
plateformes d'Internet de mise en place
de dispositifs de lutte contre la
désinformation et contre la haine en
ligne que nous avons porté sous le
mandat précédent les États généraux du
droit à l'information lancée par la
ministre de la Culture seront aussi sous
forme de proposition tout comme le
renforcement de l'éducation aux médias
et l'esprit et à l'esprit critique que
vous préconisez dans votre rapport vous
parlez de désordre infernationnel et de
perturbations de la vie démocratique
pionnier à nous avoir sensibilisés sur
les dangers du numérique sans renier
qu'il était source de progrès à
condition que des règles soient
clairement établies vous avez pu par
cette commission d'experts faire des
recommandations précises en ce sens
l'accès à l'information par sa multitude
de sources sans filtre et déréguliers
fraîche fragilise le sérieux le travail
sérieux des des journalistes et nous
rend vulnérables face aux fausses
informations diffusées en continu
s'ajoute à cela les logiques
algorithmiques des plateformes
numériques qui renforcent des
comportements et des croyances sans
permettre de s'ouvrir à d'autres prions
et de faire preuve d'esprit critique
pour lutter contre cela vous avez donc
recommandé de revoir ces logiques afin
de lutter contre le biais de popularité
en responsabilisant les influenceurs et
de faire faire et de faire plus de place
à la science comment ces mesures
sont-elles perçues par les plateformes
et est-il réellement possible d'agir sur
cela
l'autre sujet sur lequel je souhaite
vous interroger et celui du metaves ce
monde de réalité virtuelle véritable
symbole d'un monde numérique en
perpétuel évolution dans votre
conclusion vous dites le métaverse
symbolisme notre immersion progressive
dans un univers où les mondes réels et
virtuels iront jusqu'à ce confondre
pensez-vous que les règlements européens
digital services actes et digital market
actes sont des sur les services
numériques sont adaptés pour réguler le
métaverse et quels sont les risques
éthiques que vous craignez je vous
remercie merci madame la députée pour le
rassemblement national Caroline
Parmentier merci madame la Présidente
Monsieur le professeur en avril 2021
dans une interview accordée à L'Express
ou proposiez de catégoriser les
personnes complotistes en précisant
qu'elles étaient sur représentées au
sein du rassemblement national et que
leur raisonnement serait renforcé par un
trouble mental vous lisiez ainsi les
gilets jaunes l'hydroxychloroquine ou
encore la défiance vis-à-vis des vaccins
quand on porte de telles accusations
quand on se revendique d'une commission
chargée de lutter contre la diffusion de
fausses informations si sobrement
intitulé Les Lumières à l'air numérique
quand on se présente comme un expert du
complotisme on se doit de ne pas être
soi-même au cœur d'aussi nombreuses
contreverses je cite conflits et dérives
méthodologiques comme votre théorie du
temps de cerveau disponible sur lesquels
s'interroge le monde du 9 janvier 2022
je relève aussi votre mépris de
l'opinion publique parce qu'elle se
méfiait des effets secondaires des
vaccins le gouvernement a bien procédé à
la suspension du vaccin AstraZeneca que
je sache une récente étude publiée dans
le British Medical Journal jeudi dernier
confirme que les cas de thrombose sont
de 30% plus fréquentes après le vaccin
AstraZeneca d'autres effets secondaires
peuvent vaccin ont été signalés et vous
le savez très bien
votre commission a connu des débuts
chaotiques notamment avec le chirurgien
Guy valencien soupçonné d'être impliqué
dans le charnier de l'Université Paris
Descartes mais aussi faire de lance une
nébuleuse de médecin qui depuis des
années ont minimisé voire nier la
gravité du drame du Médiator il a
d'ailleurs des missionné de votre
commission alors je vous pose la
question monsieur le professeur qui
décide de ce qu'est un complot qui
décide qui est complotiste vous vous ce
terme n'est-il pas un outil de
disqualification et de censure bien
commode pour permettre à votre camp de
s'arroger le domaine de la raison je
vous remercie de votre attention
merci madame la députée pour elle et
fille
pas donc pour les républicains Isabelle
Périgot
merci madame la Présidente et merci
monsieur le professeur pour vos propos
liminaires et votre présence vous avez
évoqué l'heure de vos différentes
interviews sur la création de la
Commission les lumières du numérique
demandée par le Président de la
République que de menaces existaient du
fait de l'omniprésence des réseaux
sociaux l'une d'elles et l'émergence de
réalité parallèle qui empêcherait le
débat puisqu'elles auraient créé une
fracture du socle commun effectivement
lorsque nous suivons les réactions sur
les réseaux et en tant qu'élus nous le
suivons et le vivons intensément chaque
jour nous avons cette sensation de ne
pas vivre comme vous disiez tout à
l'heure dans le même monde mais
lorsqu'on y réfléchit les réseaux
sociaux ne sont qu'une création de
l'être humain son utilisation est faite
de plein gré et en parfaite autonomie
mettre toutes les accusations de la
fracture du socle commun sur ses outils
ne vous semble-t-il pas quelque peu
limités finalement puisque nous les
avons créés pouvons-nous ne pas
retrouver des outils pour redynamiser
notre esprit critique et transformer
l'utilisation de ces réseaux à ce sujet
vous avez fait part de votre volonté de
faire du développement de l'esprit
critique une grande cause nationale dans
votre rapport certains ont dit que
c'était le rôle de l'Éducation nationale
et que nous n'avons pas à déborder de ce
cadre pourquoi selon vous cela doit-il
dépasser le cadre de l'école vous avez
constaté dans ce même rapport rendu en
2021 que certaines logiques
étaient responsable de nos croyances ou
comportements pour vous trois piliers
sont en cause à savoir
l'éditorialisation rythmique le
calibrage social et l'influence
asymétrique qui rendent tous possible à
prévalence de certains discours
minoritaires ou extrêmes vous le disiez
tout à l'heure pour lutter contre cela
vous proposez notamment de
responsabiliser les influenceurs dotés
d'une grande visibilité numérique
notamment encourageant une modération
accrue de ces derniers quand on est vous
par là pensez-vous que le législateur
pourrait avoir un rôle important et
travailler avec les plateformes à un
cadre juridique spécifique aux
influences à forte notoriété enfin vous
conseillez de prévenir
le risque de surmodération en analysant
plus finalement les signalements
d'utilisateurs pouvez-vous nous
expliquer pourquoi et en quoi cela
consiste-t-il plus exactement merci
merci madame la députée pour les
démocrates Géraldine Bannier
merci Madame ma présidente monsieur le
professeur vous préconisez dans votre
rapport de développer l'esprit critique
vis-à-vis des plateformes et des outils
numériques il est vrai que la
fascination première pour cette
révolution technologique qu'elle
numérique laisse place à présent les
interrogations nécessaires et
indispensables quelle déontologie quelle
encadrement pour un outil qui fonctionne
parfois en activant nos plus bas
instincts vous le rappeliez dans le
livre qui vous avez valu le Prix
étudiant du Livre politique les
plateformes et autres services Internet
exploitent notre appétit pour le sexe
fascination des conflits instincts de
peur fondamentales quel impact sur
l'environnement aussi pour une
technologie qui n'est pas tout à fait
décarbonée ni en phase avec la
transition écologique requise qu'elle
accès pour tous alors qu'une partie de
la population se trouve mise en
difficulté dans la maîtrise des outils
numériques des sujets qui sans doute
aurait dû être anticipés l'innovation ne
doit on le voit jamais se passer d'une
réflexion éthique concomitante votre lix
votre livre apocalypse cognitive comme
d'autres d'ailleurs je cite notamment
l'enfer numérique particip du nécessaire
prise de conscience d'un éveil à
l'esprit critique dont vous souhaitez
qu'il soit érigé en grande cause
nationale c'est une excellente idée à
l'heure des fausses informations
nouvellesment éditorialisées cette aire
du soupçon nouvelle conçant parfois au
contact de nos concitoyens la lecture
qui éveille évidemment à l'esprit
critique et constitue une excellente
occupation pour notre temps de cerveau
disponible était grande cause nationale
en 2021 et faire de l'esprit critique
une grande cause nationale serait une
excellente prolongation une question
pour finir comment faire en sorte qu'une
évolution technologique d'une telle
ampleur que le numérique anticipe
davantage et désagréments qu'elle est
susceptible d'entraîner comment
développer l'éthique avant déploiement
même une innovation d'ampleur
merci madame la députée pour les
socialistes et apparentés Claudia
Rouault merci Madame
la
je tiens à vous remercier pour la
qualité de ce rapport nous avons en
effet besoin de répondre rapidement à
l'amplification du phénomène de ces
fausses nouvelles qui influencent nos
comportements mais aussi notre
présentation du monde au risque de faire
émerger des réalités parallèles et
devoir disparaître l'espace commun
nécessaire à la confrontation des
opinions des idées des valeurs autrement
dit à la vie démocratique vos
recommandations sont claires précises et
concrètes organisées de manière
pertinente par se faire d'action
publique privée société civile qui
s'entrecroisent il est clair que chacun
d'entre nous ne peut agir seul face à ce
phénomène toutefois un acteur majeur
nous semble un peu mis en avant dans
votre rapport l'audiovisuel public alors
que nous sommes confrontés à une masse
inédite d'information à une concurrence
généralisée des points de vue qui
s'expriment sans filtre que cette
saturation et cette dérégulation du
marché de la formation en ligne mettent
à rue des preuves nos capacités de
vigilance intellectuelle et nous rendre
davantage perméable aux fausses
informations nos rapports aux médias
bouleversé nous pensons qu'il est
indispensable de défendre un audiovisuel
public fort et indépendant
malheureusement forcée de constater que
l'audiovisuel public est toujours lui
fragilisée par la révolution numérique
et la concurrence des plateformes baisse
des moyens de d'État ces dernières
années qui ont conduit à faire des
économies drastiques et par la recentrer
forme de son financement et par des
courants politiques qui appellent à sa
disparition selon vous préservez
défendre un audiovisuel public fort et
indépendant ne serait-il pas un autre
moyen de lutter de manière efficace
contre les fausses informations je vous
remercie merci madame la députée pour
horizon et apparentés Jérémy patrie
letus merci madame la Présidente
Monsieur le professeur au nom des
députés du groupe horizon je vous
remercie de venir devant notre
commission présentée votre rapport qui a
été essentiel pour comprendre les
ressorts de la circulation des fausses
informations des théories complotistes
et leur rapidité de diffusion votre
rapport il est passionnant et je dois
bien le dire saisissant car il est clair
de manière frappante ce qu'on ne
constatons ce que nous vivons ce que
nous ressentons tous au quotidien en
profonde désordre informationsnel qui
est l'un des vertiges notre société de
notre démocratie outre les dangers
d'ingérence étrangère et de
perturbations volontaire du processus
démocratique votre rapport alerte sur
une désagrégation du socle commun et sur
une forme de cessation de Sécession
mentale pardon d'une partie de nos
concitoyens ce n'est rien de moins que
notre capacité à faire société et à
rester une démocratie pacifiée qui
insiste en danger pour lutter contre ces
risques de désinformation vous avez
identifié cinq grands axes de réflexion
et d'action parmi lesquels la révolution
pédagogique que vous appelez de vos vœux
me semble particulièrement importantes
comme les la réflexion que vous avez
menée sur l'enjeu du développement de
l'esprit critique et de l'éducation
médias ainsi que vos recommandations à
la matière faire de l'esprit critique
une grande cause nationale systématiser
la formation à l'esprit critique et aux
médias en milieu scolaire et étant de ce
travail dans la société civile est
devenu urgent et ce d'autant plus que
cet esprit critique est le ciment de
notre fonctionnement démocratique en
somme ce rapport propose un ensemble
cohérent d'analyses et de préconisations
puisque vous l'avez réalisé il y a
bientôt un an j'aimerais cependant
connaître l'état de votre réflexion sur
deux points que vous y avez abordés et
qui pourrait avoir évolué entre temps
premièrement les craintes que vous avez
et qui sont liées au déstabilisation
venus de l'étranger ont-elles été
confirmées et ce que l'ingérance
étrangère c'est exprimé c'est mêlés à la
période électorale que nous avons connue
et puis une deuxième question qui
rejoint celle de ma collègue Renaissance
sur le metaves et notamment le rapport
qui a été remis à peine plus d'une
semaine à la ministre de la culture et
au ministre délégué chargé de la
transition numérique et ce que vos
analyses ont évolué en ce qui concerne
le metavers je vous remercie merci
monsieur le député pour l'IoT Stéphane
Lenormand
merci Madame présidente monsieur le
professeur dans le chapitre 4 consacré
aux ingérences étrangères dans parler
mon collègue vous considérez qu'avec le
durcissement du contexte géopolitique
mondial que cela entraîne une logique
d'affrontement permettant permanence qui
caractérise la conflictualité de lire
numérique cette logique se traduit par
les opérations d'ingérence numérique
étrangers à être conduit à l'émergence
de menaces de plus en plus hybride qui
implique une grande diversité d'acteurs
et de mode opératoire et qui ont
compliquent naturellement la
compréhension la détection et la
prévention parmi les recommandations
vous proposez de mettre en place un
organe d'expertise d'extérieur
indépendant avec lequel les plateformes
pourraient signer une convention leur
permettant entre autres face à la
demande de retrait d'un contenu argué
d'être une fausse nouvelle réprécie
répréhensible pardon de soumettre le cas
à ces experts extérieurs dont elles
s'encageraient à suivre la vie donc dans
cette élément que vous proposez avec
interlocal quels sont les risques de
porter quand même atteinte à des
libertés essentielles de la démocratie
tel que la liberté d'expression
d'opinion ou d'informations et
finalement comment appréhender ces
risques par ailleurs vous soulignez
aussi la problématique du recours aux
hébergeurs à l'étranger en effet les
plateformes les plus fréquentées sont
pour la plupart hébergées aux États-Unis
d'ailleurs en septembre 2017 un rapport
de la DGSI alerte sur l'augmentation
constance de la masse des données
hébergées à l'aide des techniques
d'informatique notamment le Cloud ou le
nuage qui représente un enjeu pour la
sécurité des informations sensibles à la
fois pour notre société les particuliers
et les entreprises aussi ne pensez-vous
pas qu'il est urgent que la France voir
l'Union européenne investissent dans
dans le développement de son propre
système de stockage et de traitement des
données indépendants et qui en
respectera nos règles merci merci
monsieur le député pour être sûr que
notre orateur de ce matin puisse prendre
son train à 11h on va prendre le reste
des questions et comme c'est le frein de
réponse groupée pour toutes les
questions donc je passe la parole à
Violette spielbou
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Président votre rapport est passionnant
et nourrira sans aucun doute la nouvelle
mission flash d'éducation aux médias qui
m'a été confiée par la présidente de
commissions avec mon collègue Philippe
Balard
parmi les 30 propositions de votre
rapport contre les désordres de
l'information vous proposez notamment
celle de créer une cellule
interministérielle dédiée au
développement de l'esprit critique et
celle de créer une grande cause
nationale au développement de l'esprit
critique et de l'éducation aux médias
avec une systématisation de la formation
en milieu scolaire et une
sensibilisation particulièrement auprès
des élus locaux et des collectivités
territoriales députée du Nord et l'île
local nous disposons à Lille et sur les
communes de ma circonscription comme
dans beaucoup d'autres en France de
conseils municipaux d'enfants et de
conseils de jeunes qui sont très actifs
qui permettent vraiment une
participation citoyenne de nos jeunes à
des susillés très variés dont souvent
ils s'auto saisissent et ça implique
ceux qui sont souvent éloignés de la vie
de la cité pour qu'ils deviennent de
réels acteurs de leur avenir de notre
démocratie française aux côtés des élus
locaux aussi ma question est simple
comment pourrions-nous intégrer ces
instances de démocratie locale
présentent partout en France dans le
grand projet national que vous souhaitez
impulser merci merci madame la députée
Sophie blanc
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Professeur au-delà de la lecture de
votre rapport de ce triptyque saturation
algorithme publicité et du cocktail
complexe et qu'il génère une question à
vous poser qui porte notamment sur
l'éducation aux médias et à
l'information vous recommandations 24 à
29 sur l'esprit critique et EMI propose
une série de mesures adaptées à notre
système administratif créer une cellule
interministérielle cartographier les
difficultés cognitives des élèves etc
ces mesures sont dirigées vers l'état
que vous cherchez à alerter et vers
notre machinerie administrative que vous
voulez mettre en branle sur le sujet
alors j'en comprends la logique mais de
façon plus précise je voudrais vous
entendre développer notamment la mesure
27 qui indique systématiser la formation
pour les élèves dès l'école primaire et
jusqu'à près le secondaire et pour les
enseignants en formation initiale et
continue et renforcer de manière
significative le réseau de référents et
coordinateur académique dans ces
domaines alors nous nous trouvons là au
confluent de l'éducation de
l'enseignement et de la philosophie sur
un vrai choix de société j'aimerais que
vous m'expliquiez votre pensée notamment
comment armer nos enfants comment leur
donner le recul nécessaire et quels
outils mettre en place dans les
programmes pour leur enseigner le doute
et l'analyse et surtout qui va le
renseigner cela de façon objective vous
parlez tout à l'heure de révolution
pédagogique mais à quel âge elle se fait
cette révolution pédagogique est-ce que
l'enseignement
n'implique-t-il pas une certaine
stabilité je vous remercie merci madame
la députée Céline Calvez
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur
Brunner votre commission les lumières à
l'air numérique avaient pour mission
d'identifier les mécanismes permettant
de limiter la propagation des fausses
informations nuisant à la vie
démocratique et de renforcer la
vigilance des citoyens notamment sur les
réseaux sociaux quel est le sens de
votre recommandation 29 qui préconise la
création d'un continuum entre temps
scolaire université monde culturel et le
nom du travail afin de renforcer la
formation à esprit critique et
l'éducation aux médias par la même vous
pointez un besoin celui de faire de
l'éducation médias pas seulement pour
les enfants mais aussi tout au long de
la vie j'aimerais aborder avec vous deux
leviers possibles quelle est la place de
la formation à l'esprit critique dans le
compte personnel de formation qui
recense les droits acquis et les
formations dont nous pouvons des
bénéficier l'esprit critique et
l'éducation aux médias d'information
sont-ils intégrés au socle de
connaissances et de compétences deuxième
point quel est le rôle de l'audiovisuel
public dans l'accompagnement de son
continuum de formation à l'esprit
critique en particulier dans quelle
mesure les médias publics locaux je
pense à France Bleu et France 3 pourrait
se saisir de ce rôle fondamental de
formation à la deuxième médiatique
méthodique et l'esprit critique je vous
remercie merci madame la députée Maxime
minot
monsieur le professeur je souhaite
parler plus longuement de vos
recommandations sur la question de
l'ingérence numérique étrangère
nous le savons c'est un fait de plus en
plus avéré si l'intervention russe dans
l'élection présidentielle américaine a
été au cœur de l'actualité nous ne
sommes pas sans savoir que ce type
d'ingérence arrive plus souvent que que
l'on ne croit vous conseiller d'analyser
les données de campagne d'ingérence
étrangère ayant visé la conduite de la
vie démocratique française afin de mieux
anticiper le risque d'ingérence quand on
est vous par là et au-delà d'analyser et
de rassembler les données nous pouvons
donc pas envisager une intervention la
création d'un système ou d'algorithme de
protection peut-être innovant afin de
lutter notamment contre toute cette
tentatives d'ingérence et vous évoquez
également dans votre rapport le fait de
permettre de partager
le gouvernement les plateformes les
journalistes alors comment définir
réellement qui est acteur de confiance
en la matière je vous remercie
merci monsieur le député Laurent
Croisier
oui merci Madame
la une préoccupation majeure de toutes
les démocraties a l'air des réseaux
sociaux dont on peut se demander si
parfois elles ne sont pas devenues des
réseaux sociaux les utilisateurs sont
noyés sous une masse continue
d'information non hiérarchisée c'est ce
que vous avez précisé dans votre
introduction sont également orientés par
des algorithmes qui visent à enfermer
les utilisateurs dans une bulle
cognitive algorithme dans on ne connaît
pas les critères
et les algorithmes sont alors un terreau
pour la propagation de fake news et un
terreau pour le complotisme nous savons
que les moins de 35 ans prix privilégie
très majoritairement internet pour
s'informer
le rôle des parents et du système
éducatif pour renforcer l'esprit
critique à Paris alors indispensable
j'aurai une seule question pensez-vous
qu'il faille à court terme encadré les
algorithmes par la loi merci monsieur le
député angélique Ranc
il y a pas de d'accord karl Olive
le meilleur des remparts à la
désinformation vous l'avez dit c'est
suite du renforcement de la formation
critique et de l'éducation médias à
l'information vous appelez un
renforcement pour tous les niveaux
scolaires des cours qui sont dédiés
ainsi qu'à une amélioration de la
formation des enseignants sur ce sujet
la vérification de l'information c'est
l'ADN des journalistes ça devrait l'être
le Béaba de la carte de presse je
partage votre analyse et votre position
néanmoins je souhaite connaître
concrètement la place de ces réflexions
pour l'école chez nos voisins européens
ma seconde question s'il vous plaît
porte sur la formation continue chez nos
adultes alors que les élections au
Brésil et aux États-Unis ces dernières
semaines qui ont été gangrenées par les
intox et les fausses informations
provenant de Russie relayées en France
et qu'elles peuvent avoir un large écho
aujourd'hui sur la guerre en Ukraine
hier sur les élections l'intérêt de
développer l'esprit critique tout au
long de sa vie et de former aux médias
les générations qui comme la mienne ou
celle de nos parents n'ont pas connu les
réseaux sociaux à l'école s'avère
fondamentale je souhaite s'il vous plaît
connaître vos positions sur le sujet
merci monsieur le député Alexandre
portier
merci Monsieur bonheur dans votre
rapport
scientifique relative à la
désinformation porte trop rarement sur
la France et que les conclusions de
travaux basées sur des données issues
d'autres pays comme les États-Unis
principalement ne sont pas
nécessairement transposables chez nous
de ce constat une première
recommandation est dressée en vue de
soutenir l'engagement de la recherche
scientifique française sur la prévalence
de la désinformation en ligne ces effets
et les mécanismes par lesquels elle
affecte les individus la mission
recherche et enseignement supérieure du
proche de loi de finance pour 2023 qui
sera l'objet de la Commission de cet
après-midi ne traite en rien de cette
recommandation qu'en pensez-vous quel
type de travaux scientifique faudrait-il
lancer en France quel type de dispositif
faudrait-il soutenir je vous remercie
merci monsieur le député angélique Ranc
merci Madame à présidente professeur
Brunner les jeunes sont confrontés à un
pourcentage de désinformations affolants
à travers les contenus de certains
réseaux sociaux je pense par exemple à
Tik Tok en plus de propositions sur le
MI le rapport de la commission les
lumières a l'air numérique donc vous
êtes président et met les
recommandations relatives au logique des
algorithmes des réseaux sociaux
proposent des régulations sur le
métrique de la population popularité sur
l'éditorialisation algorithme ou encore
sur les influenceurs nécessaires ces
recommandations appelées que cependant
des acteurs privés souvent
internationaux j'aimerais ainsi
comprendre par laquelle lesquels moyens
la France pourrait réguler ou participer
de cette régulation empêchant ainsi les
réseaux sociaux de contrôler à ce point
l'information je vous remercie merci
madame la députée Belkhir Benhaddad
oui merci madame la Présidente Monsieur
le Professeur je souhaite vous
interroger sur la haine en ligne et le
travail législatif réalisé dans
précédent mandat sur ce sujet qui avait
permis notamment de proposer de retirer
dans un délai de 24 heures après
notification par une ou plusieurs
personnes ces contenus manifestement
illicitent tels que les incitations à la
Halle les injures à caractère racistes
et dans sa décision du 18 juin 2020 le
Conseil constitutionnel censuré ces
dispositions au nom de la liberté de
l'expression c'est l'arabe Salm
[__] il faut parfois nommer les
choses ne sont pas considérées comme des
insultes pour Facebook en tout cas c'est
la réponse qui m'a été faite il y a
quelques jours de facebook suite à ma
demande de signalement concernant à la
fois mon cas mais beaucoup d'autres
quelles sont vos réponses et vos
réflexions face à prêcheurs de haine et
à la régulation des plateformes merci
merci monsieur le député Bertrand Sorre
merci de la présidente monsieur bronet
actuellement peu de parents recours aux
outils permettant un contrôle parental
sur Internet et sur les réseaux sociaux
en 2019 seul 44% des parents avaient
paramétré l'appareil numérique de leur
enfant et 38% seulement recourir à des
dispositifs dit de contrôle parental
lors de la précédente législature nous
avons adopté une PPL de notre collègue
Bruno Studer visant à encourager l'usage
du contrôle parental sur certains
équipements et services vendus en France
et permettant d'accéder à Internet cette
proposition de loi est entrée en vigueur
le 2 mars 2002 et elle rend obligatoire
la préinstallation d'un dispositif de
contrôle parental sur les appareils
connectés vendus en France cette
activation devant se faire sur
proposition du vendeur j'aimerais savoir
si à votre avis ce dispositif et cette
obligation peuvent permettre de mieux
contrôler l'utilisation par les enfants
la confiance n'empêchant pas le contrôle
savez-vous si ses parents se sont d'ores
et des a saisi de cette obligation et si
nous pouvons envisager des évolutions
favorables je vous remercie merci le
député Emmanuel Antoine
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur
Bronner avec la loi relative à la lutte
contre la manipulation de l'information
et la loi visant à lutter contre les
contenus haineux sur Internet les
compétences de la com ont été étendues
dans le domaine du numérique un article
introduit au sein du projet de loi
confortant le respect des principes de
la République bien aussi prolonger cette
tendance il s'agit de compétences
nécessaires pour veiller à ce que les
plateformes en ligne et plus
généralement les contenus Internet ne
soient pas source de troubles et fasse
l'objet d'une meilleure régulation alors
professeur comment percez-vous ces
nouvelles activités du régulateur et
selon vous quelles autres champs de la
régulation souhaitez-vous que la comme
investisse
merci madame la députée Béatrice Piron
au désordre de l'information dans cette
assemblée nous sont particulièrement
attentifs au respect de l'intégrité des
processus électoraux ces dernières
années plusieurs pays occidentaux ont
été victimes via les réseaux sociaux les
influenceurs voire des gouvernements
étrangers ou encore via des
détournements de données d'action qui
aurait pu porter atteinte ou au
déroulement de scrutin électoraux dans
ce cadre vous proposez notamment lisez
les données de campagne d'ingérence
étrangères et on visait à la conduite de
la vie démocratique française afin de
mieux anticiper les risques et de mettre
en place un dispositif de coopération
entre plateformes institutions et
communauté académique pour réagir
rapidement aux opérations détectées
estimez-vous qu'il sera possible de
mettre en oeuvre ses dispositifs le cas
échéant seront-ils vraiment efficaces ou
vite détournées vous avez déjà eu de
nombreuses questions à propos de
l'éducation aux médias et la
sensibilisation des citoyens pensez-vous
que les moyens technologiques puissent
aider à garantir la pertinence du
merci madame la députée Annie jeune var
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Professeur une de vos préconisations
phares consiste à développer l'éducation
aux médias et il y a associé
naturellement l'ensemble du corps
enseignant alors je voudrais vous poser
une question sur le principe évidemment
je n'en disconviens pas et tant
enseignante moi-même je sais le rôle que
peuvent jouer les enseignants à la
matière pour autant cela présuppose la
neutralité des enseignants notamment à
l'égard des tests développés ou des
opinions développées par les minorités
on sait que le corps enseignant est
traversé lui aussi par des opinions qui
peuvent être elles-mêmes minoritaires
par conséquent la question que je vous
pose est de savoir comment l'on peut
garantir que cette éducation aux médias
soit parfaitement neutre
quelle garde-fou faut-il y mettre et la
deuxième question que j'aurais vous
poser concerne l'affaiblissement de la
sensibilité aux sciences je trouve tout
à fait préoccupant que dans la formation
des enseignants et ce sont les
formateurs qui le disent même peut
viennent du monde scientifique or c'est
un réel problème comment fait-on pour
réveiller les enfants à la science donc
à l'esprit critique qu'on soit même on y
est si peu on en est si peu familier je
vous remercie merci madame la députée
nous venons au terme des questions de
mes collègues donc
Estelle folesta pardon j'ai failli
oublier de mes collègues pardon monsieur
le professeur je vous remercie de vos
noms nombreux éclairages une question
très rapide sur un sujet qui revient de
manière récurrente et presque à chaque
crise sociale entre guillemets en tout
cas de la communauté sociale sur la
levée de l'anonymat sur les réseaux
sociaux voilà j'aimerais savoir ce que
vous en pensez et je vous remercie de
votre réponse
merci chers collègues là je crois avoir
fait le tour de tous les collègues qui
voulaient poser des questions donc s'il
y en a encore un l'un ou l'autre qui
veulent c'est maintenant puisque
non justement je ne l'ai pas dit
donc je vais vous laisser monsieur le
professeur répondre à mes collègues sur
les différentes questions et comme ça
ensuite vous pourrez avoir la liberté
d'aller prendre votre train
merci madame la Présidente et merci à
toutes et tous pour vos pour vos
excellentes questions
je suis pas sûr d'être comment dire
encore une fois tout à fait tout à fait
satisfaisant dans toutes mes réponses
mais je vais essayer de donner le
meilleur de moi-même évidemment
elles sont très vastes d'un coup elle
couvre quasiment tout tous les thèmes
donc je vais les prendre si vous me
permettez l'expression un peu par paquet
et puis je me tiens à votre disposition
à la demande de Madame la Présidente si
vous avez des compléments je répondrai
par mail tout simplement bien volontiers
en particulier parce que certaines
questions notamment qui relèvent des
questions des ingérences étrangères ne
sont pas directement dans mon domaine de
spécialité et je pense que mon
excellente collègue Frédéric Douzet
répondrait de façon bien plus
satisfaisante que moi mais enfin il se
trouve que c'est moi qui suis là donc je
vais quand même essayer de répondre
alors
alors d'abord les yeux émis c'est pas le
développement de l'esprit critique c'est
pas la même chose du tout je crois qu'il
faut marcher sur de jambes les deux sont
importants en réalité le MI c'est
typiquement à prendre aux jeunes et ça
c'est important à comprendre leur
environnement informationnel c'est à
dire de vérifier des sources etc
finalement de voir comment une
information se constitue comment elle
éditorialisée y compris comprendre
l'environnement algorithmique par
exemple comprendre le biais de
popularité le ce que je faisais les
supérieux enfin ça peut faire partie des
eemis la question de l'esprit critique
c'est pour ça que je préfère aussi
parler de penser méthodique c'est tout à
fait autre chose la pensée méthodique
c'est tout simplement vous voyez on
apprend à écrire à compter à lire c'est
très important mais en fait apprendre à
raisonner ça s'apprend aussi en réalité
et c'est pour ça qu'un certain nombre de
de comment dirais-je d'inquiétude qui se
sont manifestées qui sont bien légitimes
nous sommes à mon avis pas tout à fait
fondé parce qu'il notamment sur la
question de la neutralité des
enseignants vous avez parfaitement
raison Madame la Députée c'est une vraie
question mais en fait elle est pas du
tout impliquée dans la question de
l'esprit critique
alors donc les œufs émis il y a peu de
données en fait sur le résultat
pédagogique on le on le mentionne dans
le dans le dans le rapport mais les
quelques données qu'on a sont plutôt
encourageantes c'est-à-dire notamment
dans le nord de l'Europe ils obtiennent
des effets semble-t-il relativement
courageants pour la question du
développement de l'esprit critique et je
vais repréciser exactement ce qu'on doit
entendre là dedans et par là pardon et
quel procédé on imaginait dans la dans
la commission
l'esprit critique c'est en fait tout
simplement des éléments de métacognition
c'est à dire penser sa propre pensée
c'est à dire à quel moment je vais avoir
des intuitions qui peuvent être fausses
sur certains sujets et à quel moment
donc je ne vais pas faire disparaître
ces intuitions parce qu'elle peuvent
être très utile par ailleurs mais je
vais reconnaître des structures de
situations où j'ai des chances de me
tromper c'est pour ça tout à l'heure je
tenais à vous donner un exemple qui est
la confusion entre corrélation et
causalité mais il y a à peu près 150
erreurs type qui sont identifiées par la
littérature scientifique et donc ces
erreurs et l'identification de ces
erreurs elles sont absolument neutres
d'un point de vue politique si je puis
dire ou idéologique et c'est même ce qui
vous garantit le plus je veux dire de
maintenir une forme d'indépendance
intellectuelle donc je pense que quel
que soit la sensibilité politique de nos
enseignants ils ont bien raison d'avoir
une sensibilité politique d'ailleurs ce
sont ça veut dire c'est des citoyens ils
ont des idées politiques qui sont
engagés ça c'est tout à fait normal il
n'y a pas lieu en tout cas de craindre à
priori que que leur sensibilité
politique s'exprime plus dans
l'enseignement des outils du
raisonnement que par exemple dans un
cours d'histoire ou de philosophie ou de
quel autre cours qu'ils peuvent qu'ils
peuvent donner je dirais même que le
risque est plutôt moindre même s'il
n'est jamais tout à fait nul comment
faudrait-il procéder exactement ce que
nous suggérons c'est d'abord de faire
une cartographie
des difficultés pédagogiques et ça va
permettre de répondre à d'autres
questions qui va qui va faire cet
enseignement comment comment
procéder ce qu'il faut faire un cours
particulier par exemple d'esprit
critique alors la réponse nous la
donnons dans le dans la dans le rapport
et nous inspirons de ce point de vue de
l'état de la science la réponse c'est
non il ne faut pas développer à notre
avis de cours spécifique d'esprit
critique
il faut saupoudrer ces dispositifs dans
tous les cours où c'est nécessaire mais
comment savoir où c'est nécessaire et
bien ce qu'il est possible de faire et
nous proposons de le faire par exemple
pour commencer par la classe de 6e parce
que c'est en 6e que les jeunes font
l'acquisition générale de leur téléphone
portable donc ils vont être pour la
première fois tout à fait confronté à la
difficulté qu'on peut rencontrer dans le
monde numérique et se servir de la
compétence des enseignants de terrain
qui savent mieux que nous en
l'occurrence les moments dans l'année
par exemple le prof de mathématiques le
prof de physique le prof de SVT ou que
sais-je elle apprend une histoire-géo
enfin peu importe quels sont les moments
où les élèves ont plus de difficultés
pédagogiques c'est-à-dire quels sont les
moments où la proposition
programmatique du programme
d'enseignement elle contrarie en quelque
sorte les intuitions spontanées la
spontanéité intellectuelle des élèves
une fois qu'on aura fait cette
cartographie on va étudier les moments
du programme qui posent problème
et on va je suppose
convoquer un collège d'experts
psychologue du développement pour
identifier par exemple ou psychologue
cognitif sociologue éventuellement pour
identifier évidemment spécialiste des
sciences de l'éducation et j'en oublie
pour identifier quels sont les
caractéristiques de ces moments dans le
programme je vous donne un exemple sur
lequel j'ai travaillé plus
spécifiquement que la théorie de
l'évolution la théorie de l'évolution
qui est enseignée en troisième et très
contre intuitif c'est pas parce qu'on
est on se croit tous darwinien si vous
voulez mais en fait assez intuitivement
si on y réfléchit pas trop on est assez
finaliste c'est à dire qu'on commet des
erreurs de raisonnement et bien
nous avons identifié les biais cognitifs
qui sont à l'oeuvre dans ces dans cette
ce caractère contraintes de la théorie
de l'évolution il y a donc une façon de
l'enseigner cette théorie de l'évolution
en tenant compte des difficultés
intellectuelles que va ressentir l'élève
et donc profiter de ce moment non
seulement pour fermement enseigner la
théorie de l'évolution je veux dire plus
que jamais il est nécessaire de
l'enseigner fermement
mais en même temps lui apprendre
pourquoi lui résiste c'est-à-dire qu'en
quelque sorte qu'il commence à
domestiquer sa cognition ordinaire et si
on multiplie tous ces moments
pédagogiques en effet la question m'a
été posée bah je crois dès le CP dès le
CP pourquoi pas même à la maternelle
puisque il y a certains qui travaillent
sur sur ces questions je pense à Elena
parce qu'une Nelly ma collègue du
conseil scientifique de l'éducation
nationale il est possible de saupoudrer
en quelque sorte ces moments
pédagogiques tout au long du temps
pédagogique et c'est ainsi qu'on peut
espérer obtenir un transfert de
compétences parce que le problème c'est
qu'on obtient des résultats dans le
temps du laboratoire c'est quand on
stimule la pensée analytique de façon
neutre politiquement encore une fois
c'est par des petits problèmes quand
c'est un test qu'on appelle le test du
CRT le cognitive profession test donc
vous vous faites des tests et en fait
c'est comme quand on fait du sport on
s'échauffe vous échauffez un peu le
cerveau à utiliser son son ses capacités
analytiques et on voit qu'en effet on
résiste mieux dans ces conditions dans
le temps de laboratoire à des fausses
informations et on a moins envie de les
partager etc etc c'est pas magique c'est
encore une fois un fonctionnement du
cerveau socialisé simplement rien ne
nous garantit que cet effet il dure donc
le pari pédagogique qu'on propose et
c'est pour ça qu'on va faire une grande
cause nationale c'est ça voilà la façon
de faire mais alors si pour le coup
c'est un avantage c'est que on
transforme pas les programmes on fait
pas voilà on met pas un cours
supplémentaire parce que je crois qu'il
y a déjà beaucoup d'heures de cours pour
le pour les jeunes donc il s'agit pas de
transformer les programmes par contre il
y a quand même un coup c'est la
formation des enseignants et il faut
qu'ils aient envie de faire cela
cependant moi je sais pas pour vous je
reçois très souvent des lettres des
mails d'enseignants des des mails aussi
de gens qui travaillent dans les dans
les centres d'information là à
l'intérieur des collèges et qui sont
extrêmement demandeurs de de ces choses
là y compris pour les parents d'élèves
c'est pourquoi peut-être trop optimiste
mais je pense qu'il y aurait une grande
acceptabilité de ce genre de dispositif
mais ça demande qu'on se re qu'on
s'enlève les manches et qu'on y aille
tous ensemble évidemment et qu'on
explique en fait la réalité pourquoi
mais le corps enseignant comme vous
l'avez comme vous l'avez dit et
peut-être beaucoup plus conscient que la
moyenne d'entre nous de la nécessité de
procéder comme ça donc voilà
j'insisterai bien pour distinguer les
ennemis de l'esprit critique et il faut
les deux à mon avis alors mais par
contre comme nous le signalons parce
qu'on a beaucoup beaucoup auditionné
dans un temps qui était quand même assez
court ce qui nous a frappé c'est le
manque de coordination et on jette pas
la pierre encore une fois c'est
simplement ça deviendrait coupable de
continuer à manquer de coordination et
puis aussi il faut qu'on en quelque
sorte qu'on recrute les données sur ces
questions en d'autres termes on m'a
demandé aussi si les journalistes
pouvaient être impliqués il y a beaucoup
d'associations qui font ça les EMI y
compris des journalistes moi je trouve
ça formidable j'ai simplement une
inquiétude c'est qu'on ne mesure pas les
effets pédagogiques qu'on produit
et en effet il faudrait pas qu'à la fin
parce que la confiance est quand même un
problème comme je l'ai dit qui est qui
est essentiel il faudrait pas qu'on en
vienne à dire que finalement faire des
EMI c'est de se méfier de toute forme de
source d'information et que c'est ça
être intelligent non je crois pas que
que ça soit ça que ça soit ça évidemment
le l'objectif
la question m'a été aussi posée sur les
grandes entreprises sont des grandes
entreprises privées et ce qui m'inquiète
j'ai l'impression que c'est une
inquiétude partagée c'est qu'on voit
bien que ces entreprises elles ont un
pouvoir qui relève du politique par
exemple elles peuvent censurer comme
elles l'ont fait et je prends pas
position sur ces questions mais c'est
une vraie question politique un compte
de quelqu'un qui a été Président des
États-Unis d'Amérique je pense à Twitter
les Spice Donald Trump
c'est quand même compliqué de trancher
ce problème je dis pas qu'il y a pas
quelque chose en nous quelquefois qui se
réjouit de ce genre de choses mais c'est
une question politique essentielle parce
que c'est grands groupes privés ils ont
aucune légitimité politique et
démocratique ils sont pas élus
et pourtant ils agissent sur ces
questions
et on ne peut pas à mon avis faire
autrement que de penser à négocier avec
eux il y a quelque chose qui peut
peut-être les motiver à le faire c'est
le dégât sur leur image publique c'est à
dire que quand on songe à l'image de
Facebook il y a une dizaine d'années
l'image de facebook aujourd'hui ou
Instagram c'est plus du tout la même
chose évidemment donc il se préoccupe
tout de même pour les échanges qu'on
peut avoir avec eux on les a auditionnés
bien sûr qui se préoccupe de leur image
publique simplement en effet il faut
qu'ils alignent d'une certaine façon
leur intérêt économique et on peut pas
leur on peut pas leur vouloir d'avoir
des intérêts économiques ces entreprises
privées avec des considérations pour
l'intérêt général et la sérénité des
débats démocratiques mais ça ça c'est
une négociation cette négociation vous
le savez elle a commencé les mêmes très
entamée maintenant avec le digital
service Isaac qui a obtenu un certain
nombre de choses et moi de ce point de
vue je suis assez optimiste je trouve
que ce qui était obtenu et pas suffisant
mais c'est une vraie avancée sur la
question de la publicité par exemple
elles ont toutes ces grandes entreprises
quasiment ont signé ce sont engagées à
hauteur
visiblement de 6% de leur chiffre
d'affaires de sanctions si jamais le
foot la question c'est qui va vérifier
ça et on va revenir sur l'arcom et les
questions que vous m'avez posées
évidemment c'est une question
essentielle mais ce sont engagées sur un
certain nombre de points
et elles se sont engagées surtout sur un
autre point qui va me permettre de
répondre à la question de la recherche
française qui m'a été posée sur ce point
c'est l'accès aux données pour les
chercheurs ça c'est fondamental parce
que bon j'espère ne pas ne pas déranger
certaines oreilles ici mais je vais
reprendre métaphore du virus et du
vaccin malgré tout c'est difficile de
lutter contre un virus si on n'a pas
d'informations sur ce virus ou si les
seuls qui nous donnent l'information
sont des gens qui sont jugés partie sur
cette affaire donc moi je veux pas faire
de procès a priori ou ce qu'on appelle
les gafams sont maintenant les gamins
très exactement puisque c'est plus
Facebook mais mais méta mais je n'ai pas
particulièrement envie de leur faire une
confiance aveugle dans le traitement des
données de choses qui pourraient
impacter leur image publique
et donc il est très important
fondamental c'est pas seulement parce
que je suis chercheur je prêche pas
seulement pour ma paroisse que les
chercheurs puissent avoir accès à ces
données pour comprendre ce qui se passe
et en effet les chercheurs qui en
général ont accès à ces données parce
qu'ils ont aussi beaucoup plus de moyens
ça se passe un peu aux États-Unis une
grande partie des sciences sociales
complicationnelles se fait quand même
aux États-Unis et alors c'est un
problème parce que évidemment nous les
français on essaye analogiquement de
dire ça doit se passer à peu près comme
ça aussi en France mais c'est pas sûr du
tout parce qu'il y a des spécificités
quand même culturelles à notre pays nous
sommes pas les États-Unis et donc nous
devrions pouvoir accéder maintenant je
pense que le DSA va nous le permettre
beaucoup plus facilement et de quoi nous
avons besoin et bien évidemment nous
avons besoin de moyens
il nous faut des postes
il nous faut des postes spécifiquement
fléchés sur ces sujets
typiquement autour
des fausses informations autour de la
cognition humaine il n'y a pas assez de
profil de poste et pourquoi c'est
difficile ça c'est le deuxième point si
vous pouvez faire monter cette demande
j'en serais très heureux c'est une
considération pour la
pluridisciplinarité aujourd'hui moi dans
mon équipe je travaille avec un
linguiste computationnel je travaille
avec des gens qui viennent de
différentes disciplines je suis moi-même
sociologue mais on est obligé de
regarder un peu différentes disciplines
connexes parce que ces sujets sont
extrêmement polydriques en fait ils ont
plein de facettes et donc étant donné
qu'ils sont multifactorielles si on veut
bien les comprendre il faut intégrer des
compétences plurisciplinaires dans les
équipes seulement voilà la
pluridisciplinarité elle est souvent
sanctionnée encore aujourd'hui c'est à
dire qu'on l'encourage mais au niveau
peut-être parfois du DC nu ou des
sections sénates et je comprends les
collègues qui veulent des profils bien
spécifiques et complétant dans des
domaines dans des dans des spécialités
particulières c'est tout à fait
compréhensible et il faut continuer dans
cette voie là mais il faut en même temps
ménager des postes ouverts à la
pluridisciplinarité parce qu'on va avoir
besoin pour traiter ces questions donc
voilà ce que je dirais sur sur ce point
il a été il mettait aussi posé des
questions
alors je vais mettre le méta vert et
puis sur le fait d'anticiper d'anticiper
est-ce que est-ce qu'on a pas assez
anticipé les effets secondaires de de
ces questions bon moi je le prends pas
contre moi parce que personnellement
depuis 2003 donc ça ça d'un certain
temps j'avais écrit l'empire des
croyances et il y avait déjà un chapitre
sur la balkanisation possible de voilà
des espaces épistémiques mais tout de
même il est et ça c'est pour le mettre à
verre je pense qu'il faut il faut
vraiment l'intégrer il est quand même
très très difficilement anticipable de
savoir quand on a un outil aussi
complexe et qui ouvre autant de
possibilités d'usage ce que les gens
vont faire exactement en vérité
rappelez-vous le minital rappelez-vous
le Minitel tout simplement outils
formidable je veux dire franchement on
peut être fier en France d'avoir
développé qui ce qui ressemblait déjà un
peu à Internet avant tout le monde
seulement au bout de quelques années une
grande partie une partie non négligeable
du minital a été détournée vers des
tournées j'en sais rien en tout cas avec
des orienté vers le Minitel Rose voilà
bon j'ai pas de condensation morale j'ai
rien à dire là-dessus c'est un constat
c'est un fait c'est pas forcément sur
quoi on s'attendait initialement et
c'est très difficile très honnêtement de
de d'essayer de concevoir les choses qui
est sur ces technologies
elle crée une fluidité une
fluidification entre toutes les demandes
possibles et toutes les offres
imaginables c'est ça la grande
caractéristique une fois que vous avez
mis ça sur la table il faut avoir
beaucoup de courage pour imaginer ce que
les choses vont être dans 10 ans et je
pense que pour le mettre à verre c'est
exactement ce qui va se produire ce qui
pourrait parfaitement se passer aussi et
on envoie déjà poindre le risque
potentiel ou peut-être la réjouissance
c'est que ça marche pas du tout
c'est une possibilité
il se peut que ça marche pas du tout que
personne s'y intéresse à se met à vert
parce que d'abord le métabère c'est deux
choses un peu différentes c'est la
réalité augmentée ça peut être des
lunettes donc avec dans lesquelles vous
allez avoir des informations mais ça
déjà existé c'était les Google Glasses
et ça a été un four ça a pas fonctionné
du tout quant aux espaces virtuels il y
avait seconde live par exemple qui était
un outil étrange qui a eu son succès
puis qui est qui est devenu après un
désert il est plus personne dedans donc
on ne sait pas comment ça va se
développer ce qui est sûr c'est que
c'est difficile d'anticipable mais par
contre il y a quand même des promesses
aussi assez formidables c'est-à-dire
qu'on voit bien qu'au niveau de la
chirurgie par exemple au niveau de la
transmission de la connaissance
même vous dire je lis des papiers
aujourd'hui qui montre qu'en fait on
peut même lutter contre certaines formes
de stéréotypes par exemple ce type
sexiste ou ethnique si par exemple
avatar que vous jouez et quelqu'un qui
n'a pas le même sexe ou même genre que
vous ou la même couleur de peau et bien
il y a des études qui montrent que du
coup nos stéréotypes ont tendance à
baisser je suis très prudent parce que
ce sont des études assez récentes mais
finalement sont des usages auxquels on
pense pas forcément mais qui pourrait
être très intéressant et j'ai eu même à
expertiser des articles par exemple sur
les usages de la réalité virtuelle pour
lutter contre des phobies par exemple
vertige ou des choses comme ça faire des
des thérapies comportementales qui
utilisent des réalités virtuelles parce
que notre cerveau sait bien que c'est
pas tout à fait réel mais peut quand
même se confronter à des peurs donc de
façon en quelque sorte un peu atténuée
bon
nul est-ce que le tourisme pourrait être
par exemple révolutionné par par ces
questions nul ne peut imaginer
véritablement ce que ça va donner et on
peut même imaginer que ça marche pas du
tout c'est une possibilité
et puis évidemment ça c'est pas sans
impact environnemental non plus
qu'est-ce qu'elle est la balance
environnementale entre le fait par
exemple de voyager par son casque
virtuel voyagé par me visiter des musées
ou des choses comme ça ça se fait déjà
évidemment et donc peut-être prendre
moins l'avion on ne sait pas je sais pas
si ça pourra ceci pourra tout à fait
remplacer cela ça dépend du
développement de la technologie j'en
doute un peu pour l'instant mais c'est
l'utilisation de ces cases c'est de la
du traitement de données c'est pas non
plus sans impact environnemental je suis
absolument incompétent pour l'instant
pour faire la balance entre entre chaque
chose mais je pense qu'il y a des gens
peuvent le faire et c'est quelque chose
sur lequel on aurait raison de de se
pencher
sur encore la question de l'esprit
critique pardon je réponds un peu à la
volée parce que j'ai pris des notes je
suis persuadé que j'oublierai quelques
éléments je vous demande de bien vouloir
m'en excuser par avance
pourquoi il faut pas seulement consacrer
ça au aux enfants même si les enfants
sont évidemment une priorité sur le
développement de la pensée méthodique
parce que il était rappelé c'est eux qui
c'est ce sont les classes d'âge qui
s'informent le plus par les réseaux
sociaux etc mais c'est pas eux qui
partagent le plus de fausses
informations
ce qui partagent le plus d'informations
c'est plutôt les personnes du troisième
âge d'après encore une fois les données
qu'on a on n'a pas beaucoup de d'études
là-dessus mais on en a
d'ailleurs je vous annonce qu'il va y
avoir une enquête dont j'ai pas les
résultats mais dont j'aurais très bien
tous les résultats qui va spécifiquement
porter sur les 14-18 ans sur les fausses
informations on a très peu de données
sur ces questions donc ça va être tout à
fait intéressant de regarder les
résultats de cette enquête c'est dans
quelques jours qu'on va voir ces
résultats j'aurais vous aimez vous en
parler mais j'ai pas j'ai pas les
données et donc par conséquent c'est ces
outils finalement de liberté de penser
encore une fois ces outils qui je le
redis ne nous disent pas quoi penser
madame la député je reviendrai tout à
l'heure sur sur votre sur votre
intervention je pense qu'il y a vraiment
un malentendu vous êtes mal préparé à
cette audition parce que les questions
que vous m'avez posées je vais je vous
redirai pourquoi après
parce que ces outils ne nous disent pas
du tout quoi penser je me battrai contre
ça ces outils ne disent pas quoi penser
mais nous offre la possibilité de penser
librement ce qui est pas du tout la même
chose et donc de ne pas être tenu trop
captif par par exemple la suractivité
d'un certain nombre de groupes qui
encore une fois ont le droit d'exister
elle a aussi je me battrai
personnellement pour qu'il puisse
continuer à parler mais simplement tout
démocrate doit s'intéresser à la
question de la diversité inauthentique
encore une fois nous ne pouvons pas ne
pas être impliqués par ces questions et
de ce point de vue très au-delà très
au-delà d'internet on peut se poser la
question aussi sur les médias en général
il m'a été posé la question de
l'importance d'un service public de
l'information j'y suis personnellement
très attaché
je trouverais ça tout à fait dangereux
que le marché de l'information qui est
en France à la fois privé et public
bascule entièrement vers une logique
d'économie de l'attention mais
malheureusement c'est ce qui est en
train de se produire c'est ce qui est en
train de se produire une très belle
étude a été publiée sur bloss one il y a
il y a quelques jours et qui montre une
étude sur 20 ans qui analyse tous les
titres des journaux alors c'est encore
une fois aux Etats-Unis pardon donc je
sais pas si on peut exporter en France
mais qui montre que bien les titres des
journaux simplement les titres ce sont
de plus en plus indexés sur un certain
d'obsessions la peur la conflictualité
etc chose que je décris en effet dans
Apocalypse cognitive encore une fois
même si on peut critiquer les
conclusions auxquelles je j'aboutis mais
il se trouve que malheureusement elle
semble être confirmée je dis bien
malheureusement parce que je me rejouis
pas plus que ça elles sont elles
semblent être confirmées par des données
très massives de la science
et donc en effet je crois qu'en France
on a on a
les médias ont encore un statut
très important protéger par la puissance
publique et si vous me demandez mon
point de vue mais c'est pas celui de la
commission parce qu'on sait pas prononcé
sur cette question
j'espère que ça va continuer tout
simplement mais encore une fois à
condition que ces services publics
puissent être exciltrés en quelque sorte
des logiques du marché de la tension ce
qui est pas forcément le cas c'est ce
que je constate pas forcément donc il
faut réfléchir aussi à ces questions et
puis il faut il faut réfléchir à la à la
façon dont aussi par exemple les experts
sont recrutés
puisque par exemple les chaînes
d'information continue on a on a pu
auditionner par exemple Marc-Olivier
Fogiel recrute et on le comprend bien
beaucoup d'experts
la question c'est comment les
recrutent-ils
c'est tout à fait essentiel parce que la
tentation du média peut être justement
pour faire pour singer ce qu'on croit
être un débat démocratique donner 50% de
temps de parole à un expert et 50% de
temps de parole individu qui va le
contredire
c'est pas une représentation je dirais
loyal du débat par exemple si vous
organisez un débat sur le réchauffement
climatique il faut bien se rappeler que
96% je crois des publications
scientifiques vont dans le sens de
l'existence du réchauffement climatique
et dans le sens de la confirmation de
l'action de l'homme sur ce réchauffement
climatique est-ce que c'est démocratique
d'organiser un débat sur cette question
avec 50% de temps de parole à un
climato-sceptique et 50% de parole un
climatologue par exemple un scientifique
ben moi je le crois pas mais je vous
laisse débattre sur ces questions donc
là aussi je pense qu'il faut il faut
avancer sur ce point et s'il y a bien un
domaine où c'est possible c'est plutôt
le service public de l'information parce
que les médias privés sont eux beaucoup
plus pièces et points liés à au marché
de l'économie de l'attention
sur les les ingérences et étrangères
donc
est-ce qu'il y a eu une activité forte
de puissance étrangères pendant les
élections présidentielles alors je parle
avec beaucoup de prudents je ne le crois
pas trop je crois que ce à quoi
aboutissait j'ai interrogé mes collègues
mais il y avait pas encore de données
pas tellement parce qu'apparemment c'est
puissant étrangères étaient beaucoup
plus occupé par la guerre en Ukraine
donc il y a eu une absorption par contre
sur la gare en Ukraine là là vous avez
force intervention de bottes étrangers
malveillants d'ailleurs une augmentation
du nombre de comptes Twitter qui a été
identifié au moment de du début de la
guerre en
Ukraine il y a en France si j'ai bien
compris l'instant vigilume qui s'occupe
qui s'occupe de ces questions donc ça
c'est un peu c'est un peu c'est un peu
récent et je crois vraiment sur ces
questions vous aurez grand intérêt à
écouter ma collègue Frédéric Douzet on a
la chance en France d'avoir de très bons
spécialistes elle en fait partie elle
est pas la seule mais mais il en fait
partie
je relis un peu vos vos vos questions
[Musique]
alors oui je sur le sur la question des
des comptes de formation en fait je
crois que nous avons justement des
dispositifs en France qui nous
permettent d'avoir des propositions de
formation continue tout au long de notre
tout au long de notre notre
carrière professionnelle et je pensais
que ce serait enfin nous pensions pardon
que c'était un dispositif possible à
investir
en tout cas proposer peut-être que il
s'agit pas encore une fois de de rendre
cela obligatoire mais de proposer à ceux
dont on éco-citoyens qui pourraient être
intéressés ces outils qui de toute façon
leur serviront tout au long de leur vie
encore une fois apprendre à penser sa
propre pensée je vois pas très bien
comment ça pourrait nuire à qui que ce
soit et je pense sont des outils y
compris dans l'espace professionnel
parce qu'on voit pas pourquoi que les
espaces professionnels ne seraient pas
eux aussi traverser de d'éléments de
conflictualité de de fausses
informations etc
sur la haine en ligne monsieur le député
c'est une question très importante mais
que nous avons pas traité dans notre
rapport c'est une question très
spécifique qui est absolument importante
mais je m'avoue un peu incompétent sur
sur ce point d'autant que
notamment l'effet de harcèlement il y a
une question très technique très
difficile parce que chacun peut
contribuer à ce harcèlement dans une
proportion très moindre et qui va pas
considérer que c'est vraiment très grave
une moquerie par exemple etc et ce qui
est grave c'est l'accumulation donc on a
un problème d'agrégation dans les cas de
haine je parle pas des insultes directes
etc qui sont oui alors là ce qui sont
absolument scandaleuses il me semble pas
si vous voulez mon point de vue il me
semble anormal que ce type d'insulte
puisse rester sur les réseaux sociaux le
problème c'est que la plupart si vous
interrogez les grands les grandes
plateformes ils vont vous dire qu'ils
font tout pour les retirer mais il faut
bien reconnu reconnaître aussi qui sont
absolument débordés c'est ça le problème
donc un des enjeux c'est que ces
entreprises qui sont très riches
elles sont quand même très riches même
si elles ont elles viennent de perdre
pas mal d'argent là ces derniers temps
elles sont très riches elles doivent
investir massivement dans de la
modération humaine et localisée
nationalement ça c'est important il faut
que ça soit des individus qui parlent en
France qui connaissent la culture
française qui parle français c'est très
important pour pas prendre de l'ironie
ou une blague par exemple pour une
insulte parce qu'il faut quand même
laisser une certaine liberté évidemment
sur ces réseaux
mais ça ça dépend beaucoup de leur de
leur bonne volonté il y a même eu un
grand réseau social que j'ai que j'ai
interrogé LinkedIn pour les pour les
nommer qui a refusé de me dire combien
ils avaient de modérateurs
refusé c'était leur droit ils ont dit
c'est une information confidentielle je
dis mais si vous répondez ça c'est je
vais imaginer que vous n'avez pas
beaucoup voilà mais bon effectivement
c'est évidemment la conclusion auquel on
peut aboutir face à ce genre de réponse
mais c'est une question vous avez
parfaitement raison absolument
absolument essentiel que cette
modération est encore une fois faut
qu'elle soit localisée si je puis dire
sur le territoire national de chacun des
pays qui sont considérés mais il est
vrai que la France notre grand pays n'a
peut-être pas la masse critique pour
opérer des négociations qui soient qui
soit efficace avec ses grands groupes et
je crois que la taille critique c'est
l'Europe on a la chance d'avoir l'Europe
et je vous redis que dans les auditions
qu'on a fait parce qu'on a interrogé
au-delà au-delà du du territoire
national et plusieurs personnes nous ont
confirmé que il y avait une grande
admiration pour ce que faisait l'Europe
sur ces questions donc je pense que
l'Europe est à l'avant-garde de ces
points
je crois que je vais finir un peu sur ce
point mais je vais répondre quand même à
madame la députée du rassemblement
national sur sur parce que je voudrais
pas lui donner l'impression que je
pourrais vous dire vos propos sont
tellement outrés que j'ai pas besoin d'y
répondre mais je vais pas jouer ce je
vais pas jouer ce jeu là je vais vous
répondre
vous mentionnez une notamment une
interview de vous j'ai pu tout à fait en
tête mais quand je vous disais que vous
étiez mal préparé madame la députée pour
pour
ça me plaît de vous le redire pour être
sûr qu'on se comprenne bien
peut finir est-ce que vous pouvez
décider personne ne s'éteindre jusqu'à
présent
donc vous n'êtes pas le préparer tout
simplement parce que vous m'avez pas lu
parce que si vous m'aviez lu j'ai même
écrit un livre entier sur la question de
la radicalité pour expliquer que ça
relevait pas du tout de la psychiatrie
donc je sais pas où vous êtes allé
chercher que je pense qu'il y a un
trouble mental ouais
on est d'accord
d'accord bah il faudrait que je relis
cette interview mais je vous conseille
quand vous parlez à un chercheur à
universitaire de lire ses livres et de
pas vous fier sur des éléments extraits
de l'interview
oui oui d'accord ok on a compris donc et
deuxièmement qui plus servant parce que
je pense que cette remarque vous honore
pas sur l'autre point qui est plus
important à mon avis plus intéressant
c'est qui décide qui a un complot ou pas
un complot alors certainement pas moi et
là encore je pense qu'il y a un
malentendu que je voudrais lever je suis
pas sûr de vous convaincre mais en
réalité il s'agit pas d'évaluer pour moi
la vérité d'un complot moi je parle en
secret des dieux je sais pas s'il y a
des complots pas des complots ce que
j'évalue c'est la nature de
l'argumentation qui
qui comment dirais-je qui prétend être
une administration de la preuve c'est ça
qui m'intéresse c'est tout et ce qui
m'intéresse c'est de voir que certaines
formes de démonstration et bien par
exemple vous avez parlé des cas de
thrombose jamais nié qui détrombos c'est
pas moi c'est pas mon domaine de
spécialité simplement on doit
s'interroger pour juger rationnellement
de des propositions vaccinales en termes
de coûts et des bénéfices de ces
propositions c'est à dire combien de
vies sont sauvés et quels risquent on
prend toujours un risque à prendre un
médicament si vous lisez la liste
évidemment des effets secondaires il n'y
a pas d'effet moi je suis pas allergique
à la à l'aspirine et où et en prenant
simplement de l'aspirine il pourrait
m'arriver de grosses bricoles la
question n'est pas là si on veut que la
carte de la prise en compte des
problèmes sanitaires et des risques en
général recouvrent celles de la
rationalité et bien il faut faire
attention de pas attirer l'attention de
nos concitoyens sur par exemple les
coûts qui existent et les risques qui
existent en étant totalement aveugle au
bénéfice qu'on provoque et surtout au
risque de ne pas faire madame voilà
c'est ça qui c'est ça qui m'inquiète
donc non je ne veux pas faire un
ministre de la vérité mais effectivement
là aussi le réel est un OS est souffrait
que la science vous dise un certain
nombre de choses si on regarde la
cartographie politique de ceux qui
partagent des fausses informations et
bien toutes les enquêtes le monde le
rassemblement national a une bonne tête
de vainqueur et j'en suis désolé voilà
merci
merci Monsieur le
juste
alors mes chers collègues il est 11h et
j'avais promis à Monsieur le professeur
de pouvoir le libérer à 11h et s'est
engagé à répondre par écrit ou à revenir
devant notre commission effectivement
sur les questions de régulation et de
l'arcom les réponses nous les attendons
donc est-ce que vous prenez encore une
minute de votre temporis répondre oui
oui d'autant que j'ai été auditionné
aussi par la com je suis allé les voir
donc en fait leur domaine de compétences
c'est largement élargi puisque
maintenant il touche directement le
numérique il nous faut absolument une
instance de ce genre la seule le seul
doute que j'ai c'est
est-ce que l’arcome aura assez de moyens
c'est absolument considérable ce qu'on
leur demande alors ils ont ils ont une
augmentation des moyens mais ce qui en
fait est récurrent dans tous les dans
tous les sujets que nous avons traité
jusque là c'est que nous avons du mal à
nous rendre compte là aussi c'est parce
que notre cerveau n'est pas équipé
à nous rendre compte de la masse
d'information dont on parle et
quelquefois le fait qu'il y ait pas de
modération par exemple on peut on peut
interpréter ça comme de la mauvaise
volonté une décision mais la plupart du
temps c'est parce que ça passe sous les
radars de la détection n'est ce pas y
compris des des réseaux sociaux et le
risque inverse par contre c'est et on le
voit déjà point de y compris dans le
méta vert pour ceux qui ont déjà vous
êtes allés faire un tour dans le métaver
peut-être pour certains trous moi j'y
suis allé et bien vous avez une
surmodération on vous demande de signer
toutes sortes de choses pour vous
engager à ne pas faire ceci cela etc et
la surmodération c'est pas forcément non
plus une très bonne nouvelle parce que
c'est peut-être le paratonnerre que vont
sortir les réseaux sociaux pour pas
avoir d'ennuis et ça ça peut être aussi
une empreinte à la liberté d'expression
donc on est vraiment entre le marteau et
l'enclume je vais regarder avec beaucoup
d'attention de ce que va faire l'arcom
mais ce que je crains c'est qu'il n'est
pas les moyens et qu'aucune institution
n'est vraiment les moyens de résoudre le
problème de façon satisfaisante
merci beaucoup pour vos propos et
n'étant pas dans la surmodération je
j'indique à mes collègues qui à certains
moments et pour certains propos venant
de différentes places de la salle me
font les gros yeux et me demande de
façon volontaire ou involontaire de
couper le micro sachez que ici la parole
est libre et elle le restera et que les
orateurs je les supposent intelligents
avertis éduqué et en capacité de
répondre aux questions qu'on leur pose
donc c'est pour ça que les débats sont
menés de cette façon là pour que
justement on puisse avoir les réponses
aux questions que que vous posez donc je
vous avais parlé de surmodération
effectivement ça peut être un danger
pour la liberté d'expression et je
souhaite que cette commission nous ne
faisons nous ne faisons pas preuve de de
surmodération mais uniquement de
modération donc sur ces propos je vous
propose de vous retrouver à 17h ce soir
pour l'audition de la ministre
Retailleau je vous remercie